Escq 幫你做 GitHub 的一些工作術等等等等
Code Reveal 都可以做
你甚至可以拆解它其中一步來做
但你要一個完整的項目
想跟它溝通完再做
你就直接用 Superpowers 頂成了
如果你只想做寫計畫
你也可以交換它其中裡面的一個Skills
你會有任何的想跟它溝通的
跟它溝通完了呢
它都會不斷的問你問題啊
這個是一個對其需求的一個過程
其實是非常重要的
它都會問你啊
如果沒有數據怎麼辦啊等等的問題啊
大家回去可以把自己手頭上現在最想做的一個項目
比方說你想搭一個工作台
第一步應該怎麼做你覺得
我就想回去搭一個工作台
我第一步怎麼做
你把需求寫好了
直接一個Pump給這個
釣用Superpower 把Pump直接給它
說開始我們就做了
它馬上就可以幫你出計畫
然後最後你會發現
剛剛跑兩個小時
你工作台就出來了
你啥也沒幹
可以試一下
但是Token可能比較貴
所以比較貴的這個Pan和Execute的過程
就是它會識別你的任務
然後慢慢澄清你的需求
做方案對比
用什麼技術啊
實現啊對吧
然後設置確認了以後呢
它會有具體的一些字檢
最後寫成計畫幫你執行
和跟你慢慢的確認啊
你回去要搭什麼工作啊
小紅樹也好
投資美股也好
做什麼事情
你試一下用Superpower
它會給你一個意外的驚喜
好
那到這裡有什麼問題
沒有的話
我們休息一下下
待會再繼續
大家其實
上這麼高強度的課也累了
我這邊也不用太多時鈔了
那這種東西也不要求你們兩天學會
這不可能的
我都已經花了兩三個月才把這些東西做出來的吧
你聽了可能腦都脹脹了
但沒關係等你到時候要用了
很快的收工就兩個星期後
你就知道這個東西的威力了
好
好我們下次休息一下